hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones trailer QA just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
there's nothing quite like that first
giant game of thrones trailer each
season it is crazy to think that we're
gonna get to do this two more times for
season 7 and season 8 who knows about
the spin-off they haven't really said
anything about it recently really not
expecting to hear about that till we get
within the last year of Game of Thrones
here we go the nice Johnson no question
to start things off Alvin and asks if
that's Jon Snow alive at 117 like one
minute 17 in the trailer and the r+ l
equals J theory is correct does that
mean that he is now able to lay claim to
the throne since his oath to the black
will have been fulfilled because he died
and was resurrected well assuming that
really is Jon Snow and he has come back
from the dead and assuming he is the son
of Rhaegar and Lyanna he would have a
very strong claim if he could gain
supporters because Tommen is sitting on
the throne and currently has the support
of the realm in order to kick him to the
street Jon Snow would have to win
popular support and he would either have
to take the throne by force like kill
Tommen and the rest of the Lannisters or
they'd have to call a great Council
which is like a meeting of all the big
Nobles in Westeros and they'd have to
determine whether or not Jon Snow had a
more legitimate claim to the throne
really the easy way to do it is just
take the throne by force next question
sir Liu gush asks do you think the
trailer puts too much emphasis on Jon
Snow's dead body like the fact that he's
dead like I'm a little confused by your
question but I'm assuming just because
they make it seem like he's dead and not
coming back these are made by someone in
HBO's marketing department and they just
want to sell the idea that anybody can
die that doesn't mean that no one is
coming back because as we've seen people
can totally come back from the dead in a
number of different ways so yeah you
could argue that they're laying it on
really thick like look at his dead body
just sit there and stare at it for a
couple minutes but it's really just to
downplay expectations so that when he
does come back you get a red wedding
level response when the internet just
grinds to a halt for an hour next
question f nin directs I wonder if you
could help me understand why tanaris is
so much against slavery wasn't she
supported by Illyrio and the others who
promoted or at least benefit from
slavery well you get this real-world
narrative where you get a bunch of
really rich
people backing a new leader who are kind
of shady themselves but I think Daenerys
is trying to not be a tool of those who
are supporting her just to use
real-world American history here's a
really good example George Washington
our nation's first president thought to
be a very great man very great leader
owned slaves so is this weird
contradiction like the showrunners want
you to think of Daenerys is a
protagonist someone who's trying to do
good things but stumbles along the way
next question X Nomar asks going off the
possibility that Jon Snow is the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and liana stark and he
does have Targaryen blood in his veins
what if the Nights Watch traders get his
body burn it and Jon Snow walks out of
the flames like Daenerys what sounds
like you're reading tumblr fanfic that
would be amazing but it'd be I think
it'd be a little cliche I'd be a little
on the nose thematically I wouldn't be
surprised if you saw some familiar
things in the way jon snow comes back
but i'll be very surprised if he came
back the same way to nearest came back
is the mother of dragons that doesn't
mean it won't happen that way it just
means that I'm not expecting it next
question gar asks should i watch the
next season you're talking about season
6 or stay unsullied Four Winds talking
about winds of winter I would just go
ahead and watch season six there's going
to be so many things that are different
it won't look anything like the books
dan and dave probably have a good idea
of where george RR martin is headed with
his characters but they haven't read
wins a winner Martin has not give them
an advance copy of the book they're just
on the same page with where the
characters are headed as george r martin
is so some of the things that they do
will be different but thematically the
characters will be in the same place by
the time we get to the end of the series
and i'm talking like season eight a game
of thrones so from a spoiler standpoint
I think you'll be totally safe for a
game of thrones season six next question
Danny asks looking forward to this but
forgot half of what happened in season
five this is actually a good thing I'm
going to dress a little bit of season
five when I start making season 6
episode videos but you should just check
out HBO now if you guys don't know about
HBO now they started it last year that's
how I watched all of season five you get
it on demand the minute it drops you
don't have to wait an hour depending on
which time zone you live in and it's
only ten dollars a month every single
episode of Game of Thrones and anything
the HBO has ever done every TV series
all their movies it's all available
Netflix
style on demand on HBO now so just binge
watching the previous seasons is my
recommendation going into season six
next question Alfie asks what will
happen to surge aura regarding his
infection you're talking about the
grayscale it'll just get worse and worse
and worse until he dies I think what's
going to happen is is that he's just
gonna work till his last breath to try
and help tenaris he's like this really
flawed tragic hero now so I think that
they're pushing him in that direction
where he tries to sacrifice himself for
dinners knowing that there's no hope
he's going to die so he's going to try
and do everything he can to serve
donairs with the life that he does have
left next question Bruce Wayne asks so
tell me who are the Dothraki charging I
wouldn't be surprised if they were
charging the forces of young Kai like
the wise masters because they'll
probably be some other big force
attacking marine during season six in
its most likely little come from one of
the nurses other enemies there are other
forces in the East capable of marshaling
big armies that the Dothraki could be
fighting and I think most of the
conflict on this scale like big battle
conflict is going to be specific to
slavers Bay so you're talking like
Daenerys his forces versus the sons of
the harpy versus their supporters next
question mr. snorks I was bummed by the
lack of Tyrells in the trailer
desperately want to see them get more
involved and kick some ass so thanks for
pointing out that one shot in the set
yeah I mean that's a whole lot of
Tyrells and they're going to be a big
part of the season but I think it's
mostly going to be about the forces of
Highgarden trying to free Marjorie and
laura's I was never a giant fan of
Marjorie's character mostly because all
of her action had to do with trading
barbs with Circe like verbal barbs I'm
more of a fan of the street brawl so
that's why I'm so much more excited
about Cersei in this season because
she's making the leap from cutting
people down with her words to literally
cutting people down with the mountain
sword next question italo asks I just
want to see the night's king recognizing
brand somehow and then talking in that
vision or out-of-body experience he's
having well I they haven't really
explained what brand is allowed to do
while he's having these visions if he's
a lot to interact with people I don't
think that it works that way but it
would be totally badass Yeah right now
without knowing more information there's
two ways to look at it it's like
watching a movie and you can interact
with it you can only watch it unfold and
two if you want to get really trippy
about it you could theorize that he's
using the weirwood to transport
his consciousness literally through time
so either he's watching a weirwood movie
or two he's actually traveling back in
time next question Mike asks where do
you think the battle in the North takes
place but I think because it seems like
they're fighting the wildlings is
probably somewhere near the gift because
that's where the wildlings have settled
they might travel a little further south
and meet them somewhere else I don't
think it's going to be between
Winterfell and the gift sometimes the
show will play it a little fast and
loose with the map like where things
take place don't be surprised if
characters move really fast like
Melisandre at the end of last season
when she went from Winterfell to the
wall within the span of like a day but
thank you so much everyone for
submitting questions these are always a
ton of fun to do I'm gonna try and do
Game of Thrones q and A's every single
week we're getting really close they're
definitely going to be dropping some
more teasers in the future also giveaway
time congratulations to this week's DVD
giveaway it's a season five DVD bo has
David please private message me on the
back end of my channel swing get your
contact details for any of you guys that
are new to the channel giveaways are
meant to work really simply all you have
to do when I announce them is usually
leave a comment just that I'm able to
pick a giveaway winner from the comments
and be a subscriber giveaways are only
open to subscribers in the only way to
disqualify yourself as to be really
really shitty to other people in the
comments so what I'm planning is is
they'll be won Game of Thrones giveaway
each week leading up to the season and
the next one will start when I post my
next game of Thrones bonus video so that
will probably be on Monday or Tuesday
depending on when they drop new material
if something really cool happens before
that then I'll totally make a video
whenever that happens we're almost there
almost within like the one month period
so while you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here to rewatch
the trailer like five billion times and
you can click here for the captain
america civil war trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you